bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du satuc culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 6
décembre il était l'idole des jeunes
johnny hallyday la star du rock français
nous a quitté ce mercredi 6 décembre
nous reviendrons sur l'héritage qu'il
laisse dans les yvelines
son concert à elancourt en 1990 mais
aussi de l'évocation qu'il a suscité des
textes engagés de la musique urbaine
coyote est un artiste autodidacte
guyancourt toi il fera ce samedi la
première partie des sages poètes de la
rue et de passer à la batterie des
chants sacrés et profanes ukrainiens les
cinquante chanteurs du choeur à corinne
seront sur la scène de la salle
jacques-brel de montigny-le-bretonneux
un concert à l'occasion des 20 ans de la
formation en présence d'une troupe venue
d'ukraine
j'écris ces mots sans y croire et
pourtant c'est bien cela mon homme n'est
plus c'est par ces mots que laeticia
hallyday a annoncé le décès de la
légende du rock français johnny hallyday
ce sont près de 60 ans de carrière 50
albums studio 110 millions de disques et
neuf stade de france
une carrière sans précédent en france le
rockeur a une relation particulière avec
les yvelines dans les années 60 il vit
deux ans à montfort l'amaury une connu
une commune qu'il a connue grâce à
charles aznavour à l'image voyait un
tweet de johnny hallyday publiées en
2015 sur le réseau social est en plateau
avec nous bernard delattre
on sort vous êtes ans l'ancien
journaliste des nouvelles de versailles
mais aussi un fan d'autres jolies alors
vous allez nous racontez vos souvenirs
de rocker mais avant nous avons tendu le
micro aux saint quentinois
quelle image je vais garder de johnny
ben je pense qu'il a marqué la chanson
française un bon chanteur qui nous
accompagner
pratiquement eu d'autres âge tout le
long de notre d'autres villes a
découvert on était tout jeune toute hâte
au une très très bonne image de lui
on se rappellera de tous ses titres de
chansons telles que l'oral pénitencier
noir c'est noir
c'est un grand moment un grand homme qui
tissent en bas c'est quelqu'un quand
même exceptionnel
je crois que tout tout tout le monde
regrettera ce ce personnage qui étaient
hors normes
bah ça va faire trois quatre générations
qui vont être atteindre c'est plutôt
rare j'ai 51 ans elle avait nié mon
enfance j'ai okalys que de cesse de lui
chez moi mais malgré tout ce qu'on aime
goûter de chez soi sans ça a bercé notre
jeunesse c'est le premier sou que j'ai
fais que me voir ici sur johnny élite et
malheureusement notre génération garde
une image de lui un peu dans l'agonie à
toujours faire des fêtes news sur les
skis murray ce qu'il meure pas c'est un
phénomène c'est comme c'est un peu comme
un michael jackson en a l'impression que
c'est des stars qui sont limite immortel
donc sais c'est un peu triste je les
connais depuis tout petit en gros 20 il
fait partie de l'histoire et au même
titre que jean d'ormesson sert d'écran
qui vient de nous quitter et verdâtres
l'image c'est tout à fait ça il a
accompagné nos vivres il nous a aidé à
vivre
moi j'étais ado j'avais 16 ans 68 et on
a 14 ans et au lycée on a entendu le
rock'n'roll tout tout de suite avec les
potes on s'est dit c'est ça c'est la
musique qui nous accroche après on a
compris pourquoi quand on sait d'où ça
vient le blues toute l'histoire cas
derrière ces des racines très profondes
cette montée du rock'n'roll c'est un peu
sociologique ça s'explique aussi nos
parents nos grands parents ont connu des
tranchées de 14-18 nos parents les
privations de la guerre de 39 45
c'est une génération qui travaillait
beaucoup mais mon père pratiquement
jamais pris de vacances c'était de
travail travail ma mère pareil huit
enfants et nous
on parlait pas à table fallait bosser
bosser et cette musique arrive c'est
tout de suite on a accroché en plus il y
avait les l'exotisme à peu américain ça
nous a fait rêver et donc être johnny
pour nous c'est un peu le grand frère
c'était notre grand frère
il y avait sept huit ans de plus que
nous c'était comme un grand frère que le
grand frère que j'ai pas eu tout ça et
avec les potes on écoutait ça et on
retrouvait johnny dans les bals du rouge
et or province sur la loire à côté de
gueugnon tous les ballons joués du
johnny les boums les surprises parties
c'était le johnny aussi le rock'n'roll
et comment ça se fait que 60 presque 60
ans de carrière plus tard on parle
toujours de joe n'est pas ce que je
faisais c'était l'époque mais il a
toujours su s'adapter quoi il
il a travaillé toujours avec les les
nouveaux auteurs par berger goldman tout
ça il a su s'adapter il a il a été
épique à une époque tout ça mais ça ce
qui le caractérise c'est sa voix quand
il ya une voie unique au monde quoique
même les américains n'ont pas
d'équivalents peu à part peut-être bruce
springsteen tout seul on l'appelle
confessé une voie puis un style les
ch'ti rock'n roll et toute une légende
orphelins tous à une histoire un peu
fantastique
une sorte de conte de fées moi je suis
encore plus attaché à ce sujet d'origine
belge est aussi mon grand-père était
belge en 14 ans s'était réfugié en
france pour s'engager dans l'armée
française
donc il ya ce côté un peu balle jocic et
qui me plaît beaucoup chez johnny et ce
style de vie quoi la générosité le
partage
quand on allait à ce spectacle on en a
plein les mirettes déjà eu lieu pas très
loin
pas très loin d'ici alors depuis
l'annoncé de son décès les hommages à
fleurs notamment du monde de la culture
alors omar sy le comédien né à trappes
dit sa chance d'avoir connu un
inoubliable
jean dujardin qui a grandi à donner son
premier spectacle à plaisir voit dans sa
rencontre avec eux johnny hallyday un
honneur et un plaisir
bianca n'est plus roi d'origine lui
aussi salue la gentillesse la
bienveillance la curiosité ou encore
lent vie dure aux cartes vous même qui
est un fan de dunes à l'idée vous avez
pu voir à une dizaine de reprises en
concert dont l'un d'entre eux a eu lieu
octobre 1990 au palais des sports
d'elancourt plus exactement vous y étiez
vous même parmi les 2000 fans tout à
fait où en étaient au premier rang avec
hervé martin qui était confrères des
nouvelles de versailles qui est
malheureusement disparu alors c'est
toute une histoire parce qu'il faut
savoir que le premier imprésario de
johnny georges leroux a été maire
d'elancourt de 71 à 77 donc à voir alain
danet tout ça monsieur révélant que 77
et donc 90 monsieur leroux n'était plus
maire y tenait un café et d'un coup donc
nous sommes allés le voir avec hervé
martel pour lui demander on voudrait
avoir un entretien avec johnny quoi
c'est ce qui est très difficile à voir
la file et donc il nous a expliqué plein
de choses sur johnny qu'il avait fait
ses débuts le roux était aussi le
manager des poppys d'antoine tout ça il
nous expliquait plein de choses que
johnny est un garçon un peu timide mais
un peu un peu enfin pudique très pudique
tout ça et pas du tout bagarreur
contrairement à son image qu'elle a dont
il a beaucoup souffert c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'il s'est réfugié à montfort
l'amaury mais ce concert de 1000 fans à
elancourt comment c'était ça me fait un
mauvais sens des nerfs c'est un battant
jeudi qui a habitué au grand palais des
sports 20 à 30000 personnes 50000 locaux
et ils ont bloqué à 2000 places pour des
raisons de sécurité déjà ce qu'on aurait
pu mettre trois mille personnes mais la
sécurité déjà j'avais déjà quelques
problèmes
donc on avait dit pas plus de 1000
personnes donc le georges leroux nous
avait donné du contact mais qui n'était
plus valable
on nous avait dit venez dans l'après
midi johnny fera les essais voix qui en
fait c'était pas lui il a une doublure
voix
ensuite on nous a dit ouais on nous a
dit bah après le concert vous le verrez
peut-être face qu'on a obtenus on a
obtenu deux places privilégiées on était
dans les barrières quoi on était à deux
mètres j'ai pu faire des photos vraiment
à deux mains qui est à l'antenne
et justement vous avez beaucoup parlé
des lampions parce que la commune a
aussi réagi en la personne de son maire
et président de saint quentin en
yvelines jean michel fourgous qui rend
hommage au rock au rocker il ya aussi
aurore bergé la députée de la 10è
circonscription qui compare les motions
de cette disparition à celle du décès de
victor hugo en 1885
l'ancien député des yvelines benoît
hamon qui estime que c'est comme si
paris perdait sa tour eiffel pour
bertrand guillon c'est aussi les toutes
premières cassettes audio alors je vous
propose bernard de lattes qu'on parte à
voisins le bretonneux puisqu'en 2005 en
août johnny hallyday faisait escale
un reportage de wilfrid richy et patrick
jacques de dixmude
enfin cette chanson
pas cette chanson oh non non c'est cette
époque-là jane quoi ce salarié ne
travaillait pas encore dans
l'établissement mais il fredonne
pourtant ses chansons en août 2005 et
johnny hallyday tourner quelques scènes
du film jean philippe ici dans ce pub à
voisins le bretonneux et aux alentours
le chanteur à leurs acteurs donnait la
réplique à fabrice luchini
[Musique]
je me suis-je
pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi tu m'as parlé ses proches de la
réalité un rêve tes conneries tu as
raison
j'ai toujours été jaloux
je suis johnny lors de ce tournage le
fils du gérant qui depuis a repris la
sphère familiale était présent on a pu
l'apercevoir venir parce que c'est vrai
qu'il était très entouré personnes
pouvaient pouvait l'approcher et étant
donné qu'il a tourné sur le film à
l'extérieur abandonné la tête d'un gloss
et qu'il a voulu aller aux toilettes est
le seul endroit pour aller aux toilettes
c'était de passer par le par le
restaurant donc nous on a pu rentrer
dans le restaurant et puis on a pu on a
pu voir johnny d'approché du coup
prendre une une petite une petite photo
c'est le seul moment où on a vraiment pu
l'approcher de près la photo de famille
à figure en bonne place dans
l'établissement pour le plaisir des
clients toujours amateurs d'anecdotes
luchini était ici
aubers don qui rentre dans le bar et
pour le tournage du film et boit un
verre de whisky
il faut savoir que la bouteille de
whisky était plein au début du tournage
qu'ils ont fait à peine trois quatre
fois donc la bouteille il a réellement
me jean-philippe imaginer la détresse
d'un fan de johnny perdu dans un monde
parallèle où son idole n'existait plus
un monde devenu aujourd'hui
malheureusement bien réel
en grand fan de rock vous pouviez
bernard delattre en 2011 un recueil de
nouvelles folk et rock des années 60 et
donc bonne dynamique et nous ce n'était
bien sûr et figurez vous y parlez d'un
concert donné à montréal en outre 75
tout à fait à l'époque je travaille à
montréal j'étais dans une crêperie
bretonne varman j'étais étudiant j'avais
travaillé tout l'été et il ya un concert
de johnny en plein air francofête
on y va bien sûr avec tous les copains
des copines et là c'était dingue
qu'avaient choix trente quarante
cinquante mille personnes en plein air
et il y avait non seulement johnny mais
sylvie vartan
ils étaient encore ensemble 75 il était
magnifique tous les deux quoi
resplendissant et là on était fier
d'être français quoi parce que c'est du
super chaud tout ça et à la fin du jeu
ni à l'époque restait encore il a il a
alors il y avait une file d'attende
dingue pour aller demander des
autographes
car il ya plein de gens qui disaient
ouais je dit rappel ont été à l'école
ensemble j'ai fait une maquette de 10
que tu peux écouter puis d autres que et
jeudi on est cousin tu peux me prêter de
l'argent pour une boutique c'était que
ce à quoi on a compris qu'à un moment il
a une en a eu marre quoi c'est tout le
tout le monde lui demander des choses et
où tu en es c'est du show c'est une
personne ou gueule comme certains le
disent c'est aussi des chansons qui ont
marqué patrick jacques de dixmude
attendu un micro et coûteux que je
t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime que
je t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime
requins
la nuit pour nous de jusqu'à pas oublier
parole à jean marie si tu savais tout le
mal que l'on me fait moins beau mari si
tu savais voilà non mais c'était parce
que du coup ça fait le baril une
disparition qui bien sûr mais le public
français en émoi alors liliane jacob
habite à voisins le bretonneux elle ne
fera pas le déplacement à mende la
coquette le lieu de résidence du rockeur
mais l'émotion est bien là qu'est me
lambert l'a rencontré
[Musique]
en peuvent gêner dans ce paradis comme
beaucoup aujourd'hui
liliane a perdu son idole ses souvenirs
c'est justement ce qui lui restera de
celui qui l'a accompagné depuis ses 13
ans j'avais une amie qui avait deux ans
de plus que moi donc c'était la grande
voile à petit puis un jour elle me dit
il ya johnny hallyday qui sort à 1,10 et
nous la partie acheter ce fameux disque
qui est sorti en mars 1960
j'ai pratiquement tous ses disques
toujours tous les albums mais en fin de
compte on a de la peine on a de la peine
et puis alors comme tu écoutes les
témoignages de tout le monde est obligé
d'avoir une grande peine s'est il fait
partie de ma vie depuis l'âge que j'ai
13 ans et j'en ai de 70 à une vie
rythmée par les sorties d'albums et les
concerts fans dévoués liliane a suivi
sont jaunies partout même à l'autre bout
de l'atlantique monde à secouer
oubliable cm de neige grèce qu'en 1981
[Musique]
merveilleux vegas aux parents me faire
ça pour mes 50 ans est un vrai beau le
départ à l'aéroport des petits génies
partout des dans l'avion dans l'avion
tout ce qu'on a eues mais je pourrais
partie mille fois à las vegas je
n'aurais jamais un voyage comme ça et on
est des femmes
c'était formidable pour se rappeler ces
bons moments des objets à l'effigié de
son icône des dédicaces et des photos
pour l'entourer dernière acquisition en
date de son club
les calendriers 2018 malheureusement que
johnny ne verra pas le calendrier du fan
club de nîmes et alès ayant nahd
voilà ils en ont fait d'eux une
collection qui continuera de s'agrandir
malgré la perte et la tristesse ne
restera que les saisies
mais resteront sur scène ou reste toutes
ses chansons
[Musique]
une émotion palpable merci bernard
delattre d'être venus témoigner en ce
plateau alors nous terminions cette page
qu'on semble consacrée à johnny hallyday
avec un medley concocté par nos moteurs
souvenirs souvenirs
[Musique]
noir c'est noir
iv
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
on continue ce magazine avec une
nouvelle invitée et un autre qui va tout
à fait tout de suite nous rejoindre
sylvie chemin roy vous êtes présidente
dacoury ni le coeur basée à saint
quentin en yvelines
ma petite question la première avant de
parler de l'association johnny hallyday
pour vous c'était qui vous savez on peut
faire partie d'un choeur de chaux et
craignant ai adoré johnny hallyday
johnny hallyday s'était c'est toute mon
enfance et toute mon adolescence il nous
a une masse j'ai pratiquement le même
âge que tony donc vous pouviez imaginer
la la somme de souvenirs qui lie à
derrière toutes ces années et vous
connaître alors artistes aiguillon pour
toi venez donc aujourd'hui johnny s'est
pas totalement la même génération mais
bien parce que ça vous a marqué alors
pas pas plus que ça mais effectivement
c'est un très grand artiste du coup on a
forcément changé forcément entendu
parler
après effectivement un c'est pas c'est
pas facile à battre
voilà c'est pas forcément mon univers
totalement votre association à corinne
et fête cette année ses 20 ans pour
l'occasion de concerts et des invités la
chorale boyan absolument donc comme vous
le disiez accords signés fête ses 20 ans
accords signés a été créée en 1997 par
rené tronche quelqu'un qui avait une
envie folle de chanter non vie folle
aussi de créer du lien social
donc il a créé cette chorale inter
entreprises qui a évolué au fil des
années et qui est devenue ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui c'est à dire une un choeur
de chant ukrainien dirigé par facile
boris lui-même champion absolument
comment on vient chanter des chants
traverse est pas totalement notre
univers c'est pas notre univers ça s'est
fait de façon fortuite
au fil des années à corinne y a eu
différents chefs de choeur puis un jour
une chef de choeur d'origine russe et
ukrainienne s'est présentée elle est
restée un certain temps il est reparti
c'est la vie et elle nous a présenté
vassili bost rizki arrivée d'ukraine et
dans ses bagages il y avait des chansons
extraordinaire et et voilà voilà le
chemin sont deschamps actuel de chants
anciens il y a de tout il ya des chants
actuelle les champs siens des chants
traditionnels sacrés et profanes et des
chambres des plus populaires qui sont
transmis en ukraine plutôt de façon
orale alors une cinquantaine de
chanteurs amateurs mais passionnés c'est
ce qui vous a rassemblé tous
complètement pression' est très
passionné je crois que de toute façon
pour chanter en ukrainien vaut être
passionné parce que notre chorale nous
sommes une petite cinquantaine dans
cette cinquantaine nous avons trois
choristes qui sont d'origine ukrainienne
de d'origine polonaise et le reste eh
bien non non nous ne nous ne lisons pas
le ciri be dans toutes nos partitions
sont en phonétique
mais ça se passe très bien c'est pas
toujours prêt à prononcer ce n'est pas
du tout notre notre langue
non c'est pas notre langue c'est pas
plus dur c'est quand vous êtes motivé et
que vous ne connaissez pas une langue
étrange elle que de vous devez chanter
dans cette langue étrangère que ce soit
du latin de l'allemand du duo de
l'ukrainien de l'arménien quand la
volonté est là quand la motivation est
là et puis vous savez on a un chef de
choeur quand même qui est assez
extraordinaire tout notre tract comme je
vous disais tout nos partitions sont
traduits en phonétique et en plus on a
une traduction orale
on sait exactement ce qu'on chante alors
je propose qu'on écoute en extra merci
[Musique]
ap
alors ce week end deux concerts samedi 9
décembre à rambouillet et le dimanche à
la salle jacques-brel de
montigny-le-bretonneux avec des chants
traditionnels sacré et profane
absolument samedi donc ce sera à
l'église saint lubin de rambouillet le
concert est prévu à 21h et dimanche à
15h30 à la salle jacques-brel de
montigny-le-bretonneux
alors ces chants traditionnels et
viennent d'ukraine oui mais c'est une
époque particulière celle de tata le
pôle du fait de leur histoire un peu
alors oui c'est vrai que nous approchons
des des fêtes de noël donc une grande
partie de ces champs sont des chants de
noël mais pas que il représente en fait
des moments assez important de notre
chorale tout au long de ses dix derniers
dix dernières années que nous avons
passées justement avec vassil bonbis
merci se lèchent marois les mois qui
vont venir découvrir les chants profanes
et sacrées ukrainien rendez vous
dimanche à 10 décembre à montigny le
bretonneux ses généraux en face de vous
un artiste guyancourt toit de la musique
aussi mais dans un style totalement
différent
coyote vous proposez vous de la musique
urbaine tout à fait donc voilà ça va
faire donc depuis 2000 d'accord que
je fais de la musique donc
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de faire
progresser tout simplement mon art en
créant un groupe aujourd'hui constitué
de quatre personnes donc effectivement
le parcours que j'ai assez atypique
parce que je suis autodidacte je n'ai
pas vraiment de deux grosses structures
qui me suit l' avantage que j'ai c'est
que le fait de faire la première partie
donc de deux grands artistes samedi
prochain me permet d'avoir un tremplin
pour pour avancer pour aller plus loin
tout simplement vous avez baigné dedans
de textes tout à fait donc moi je suis
issu de classes moyennes j'ai grandi
dans des conditions plutôt à la modeste
puis entouré de gens qui aimait bien la
danse le break ce genre de choses la
musique vous mon père est notamment
musiciens et effectivement on va dire
que je j'ai baigné dedans très très
jeune à savoir que bas les deux artistes
auxquels je vais faire la première
partie font également issu de bain ddd
cultures urbaines en prend un petit peu
plus tard mais vous préciser vous fait
la première partie des sages poètes de
la rue et de pacy qui sont aidés non
très remarquée dans ce milieu alors vous
dans votre poche vous proposer aussi des
influences r'n'b et jazz
je viens de votre famille pas vraiment
c'est plutôt du fait que j'ai un côté
assez éclectique assez ouverts d'esprit
au niveau de la création musicale donc
effectivement ça peut arriver de prendre
un simple un sample de jazz alors c'est
un peu je veux dire otis redding pour
pour référence mais ça peut être un
autre artiste la musique africaine
également la musique classique
ça peut être du beh alors effectivement
et j'ai une très large palette au niveau
du g7 effectivement alors voilà après il
faut frac est une espèce de deux lignes
conductrices pour qu'on reconnaisse bien
le style musical mais pourquoi pas oui
justement vous avez passé votre style on
va écouter un extrait de dans vos titres
d'accord des néons france la peau foncée
d'entendre la faune souffrance elle
laisse tomber ils peuvent tous pensent
et a pas fait l con est à résister bonne
pub
t'as pas fait le contrat résister
il en sort dans la rue tâche armée d
enfance la peau foncée tentant dire la
france aux français
laisse tomber ils veulent tous pensent
et a pas fait cours est à exister
balbala à résister alors le 9 décembre
vous êtes sur la scène de la batterie à
guyancourt
qu'est ce que vous allez proposer ces
les morceaux vous avez écrit n'est
reprise peut-être venant pas un punk pas
nécessairement des reprises plus d'aider
des créations que j'ai fait moi même
donc je suis auteur compositeur
interprète
je travaille sur une application qu'on
appelle reason qui une usine à gaz qui
est assez conséquente au niveau de la
création
donc voilà clairement j'ai créé ma
propre musique j'ai comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure j'ai utilisé des samples
pour me servir justement de cette
culture musicale diverses et variées et
et aujourd'hui effectivement voilà je
propose donc une première partie avec
une dizaine de titres d'accord dont deux
qui seront faits par par les artistes
que j'ai avec moi juste après ce que
c'était vous avez pu aller travailler à
la batterie puisque vous êtes
actuellement en résidence avec eux c'est
sur la batterie la salle de musique
exactement de la batterie m'a gentiment
proposé donc deux jours de résidence qui
m'a servi à bien structuré donc mon set
pour le concert on a eu donc deux jours
de 10h à 12h et de 14h 18h ce qui est ce
qui est vraiment très bien pour pour
pouvoir avoir une bonne préparation de
seine
vous les avez s'était plusieurs fois
vous n'êtes pas seul sur scène vous avez
un bac heures et une chanteuse
c'est ça alors le biker c'est christophe
qui est bien connu de la commune de
guyancourt qui a été pas couronné mais
qui a eu 1 1
qui a été reconnue par la mère de
guyancourt comme quoi c'était un des
jeunes les plus représentatifs de la
commune ce qui est très bien pour lui et
ma chanteuse qui est donc être de
sannois du 95 qui est une très très
grande artiste à mon goût puisque elle
fait de tous âges chante en anglais
elle fait du rap également elle fait
elle chante elle est très très très très
très très bien au niveau au niveau du
chant et voilà quoi je vois là aussi ils
ont la vingtaine
alors c'est important pour moi surtout
dans ma commune de pouvoir leur donner
cette force et puis les guider au niveau
artistique parce que effectivement dans
l'endroit où je viens enfin là où
j'habite
les jeunes sont en quête de sa demande
énormément des gens qui puissent être là
pour les aider au niveau du milieu a du
monde artistique
alors que ça peut être du hip hop de la
danse des spectacles
et voilà donc moi je suis là pour leur
apporter ce besoin et qu'ils soient plus
tard acteurs de ce que de ce que je leur
donne comme conseil merci coyotes alors
on le rappelle vous serez en première
partie de passer et des sages poètes de
la rue
une soirée musique urbaine à la batterie
de huy en cours et le concert débute à
20h30
cette culture est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi le
magazine est à revoir sur notre site
internet ou sur notre application à
mercredi prochain
[Musique]